all right so it's one more thing on the
Rubin report and I wanted to ask you
guys because I think you do have
something kind of interesting going on
together is that the way you guys have
become public figures you in the in the
digital space and in the YouTube world
and you from reality TV this is the
future of media I firmly believe that
which is why I'm doing this
how does it feel in terms of being a
public figure in this new world like
we're not TV stars we're not movie stars
per se or I've never been in a movie so
not per se literally but that you're a
public person in the digital space how
does that feel in 2013 for a youtuber it
feels good because I'm a normal person
I'm not a celebrity whatsoever and if
anyone says otherwise I correct them
don't worry I'm nobody but seriously
it's it's it's interesting it's if you
can't if you go on auditions all the
time because I wanna be an actress we go
on auditions all the time and you're not
getting parts that you want why not
create it yourself put yourself out
there build an audience yourself that's
the only way up now is such a gamble and
Whitney for you you came from the
reality world and that reality seems to
be I think we may be finally a little
bit how do you how do you blend like
what your public persona is do people
expect you to be the reality person I
mean well I think what I kind of lucked
out because I when I went into it I just
was kind of like ah this is me
uncensored you know and looking back
sometimes I was shocked and appalled at
myself but you know I think that when
people meet me in real life I think that
they knew what they were getting and
they see me and it's the same thing and
it kind of transferred over fairly
equally so you know I I think having my
personality kind of consolidated down
into 45 minutes it seems like I'm a
always at that time had always a new
girlfriend or a cocktail in my hand
which is not true it's only half the
time I'm married now
but now I think people pretty much see
what they can get and I hope that I come
out as
be just being relatable yeah you know
and I people I would hope feel
comfortable approaching me and then you
know I can be a voice but at the same
time you know be real and have faults
yeah all right so final thought on this
how empowering is it to you guys to sort
of own your brand and everything right
now like even ten years ago like if you
wanted to be a public entertainer or
whatever it is we all are like the
network owned you or you were you know
had to take gigs that you didn't want
because your manager your agent want to
and now there's all these people I mean
there are youtubers that are way bigger
than the two of us that are making
literally millions of dollars it's
pretty empowering to just own your stuff
right
it feels amazing and I do have a manager
but he's so cool he lets me own YouTube
like everything I do on YouTube is mine
yeah and that's such a great feeling
because I've had networks screw me over
YouTube Network they are noted for that
Oh YouTube network use networks yeah
yeah so to be on your own as an
independent youtuber or part of a
network that is very accepting and
they're they may know what you want and
they want to help you that's just that
feels great yeah and what about for you
because you're I feel like you're always
doing like a little bit of everything
and yeah but it's you and you're owning
it yeah it's me I mean it's been an
amazing opportunity to like just create
myself into a business it's like you
know kind of going this alternative
route and being able to kind of blaze
your own Trail and you know it's been
really rewarding and challenging at
times but you know I think that this is
kind of like in this day and age we get
to redefine this concept of
entertainment and I'm glad I could be
part of it for sure how small and that
was a fitting ending Bri thank you
Whitney thank you I think we're gonna go
into some sort of business it's gonna be
like a smaller Walmart kind of thing
environmentally sustainable very
pro-lgbt you know that whole thing they
spin the reuben report I'm Dave Rubin
and we'll do it again